non
c'est rible vérité à propos de l'
incendie belfort un jeune homme de 23
ans a avoué c'est lui qui avait mis le
feu à l'immeuble week end électoral
l'enjeu des municipales soirée non-stop
sur antenne 2 dimanche ce soir au
microscope marseille
pas d'état de grâce pour george bush les
difficultés commencent déjà le sénat a
refusé que john towers soit ministre de
la défense
la télévision peut-elle être un outil
pour l'enseignement
jacques pomonti vient de rédiger un
rapport il est notre invité
bonsoir lincendie de belfort déjà
l'horreur 15 morts et une dizaine de
blessés vous en souvenez tous des jeunes
les yeux encore plus terrible il
s'agissait bien d'un incendie criminel
l'incendiaire a avoué s'est lui aussi un
jeune 23 ans il est passé aux aveux en
quête de bruno gex l'émotion de quelques
habitants de belfort après l'annoncé par
le procureur que le suspect est passé
aux aveux à une centaine de mètres du
palais de justice ce qu'il reste de
l'immeuble ravagé par un incendie qui a
coûté la vie à 15 personnes
c'est ici que xavier kurt elle logeait
c'est là dans les poubelles au
rez-de-chaussée qu'il a mis le feu
javier curtet est également soupçonné
d'avoir provoqué une quinzaine
d'incendiés en janvier dernier dans ce
quartier hlm des résidences il y avait
trouvé refuge depuis deux jours chez son
frère jumeau et sa belle soeur
c'est un garçon qui manque à ma chambre
qui avait les craintes du fei plutôt
immature mais rien de
de ce qu'on peut dire sur à l'heure
actuelle tout seul ou comment se
comporte-t-il quand ils venaient aux
bornes et non les deux copains du dge
vache morte ou 10 timide au bar il avait
toujours peur des gens et client est ce
le retour dans son coin dévié curtet
travailler ici depuis quinze jours au
collège de vauban comme aide cuisinier
de son passé peu de choses
un séjour dans une institution
spécialisée les tendances pyromanes yak
dit on xavier kurt est en garde à vue
depuis hier au commissariat de belfort
peut être inculpé demain midi ce soir
l'esprit était au recueillement dans
cette chapelle ardente de l'église de
belfort une messe dite à l'intention des
15 disparus week-end politique chargé
bien sûr avec les municipales c'est
dimanche que vous votez et si vous
regardez antenne 2 vous serez des
privilégiés avec une grande soirée
électorale non-stop nous serons les
seuls à faire de l'information toute la
soirée
le journal donc à 19h15 blanche ensuite
début de la soirée électorale 19h50 elle
sera animée par claude sérillon et tout
le service politique d'antenne 2 emmenée
par gilles leclerc et jean louis lawson
un seul mot d'ordre priorité aux
résultats à deux sera présente dans 50
lieux différents en france pour vous
tenir au courant
et dès 20h première estimation dans ce
décor est aussi dans plus d'une dizaine
de villes
et puis si vous voulez avoir des
résultats encore plus détaillées vous
pourrez aussi interroger le minitel 36
15 codes civique
vous aurez tous les résultats des
communes de plus de 3500 habitants
regardez pour les câbles et du minitel
les accros de la calculette électorale
des résultats comme vous n'auriez jamais
osé les rêver grâce à tous les
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'intérieur
grâce à antenne 2 tous les chiffres en
temps réel département par département
ville par ville et liste par l'isq une
innovation cette année la transparence
dépôt des bulletins dans chaque bureau
de vote
dépouillement des enveloppes collecte
dans chaque préfecture puis
centralisation des données dans 9
centres régionaux du réseau
enfin dernière étape les ordinateurs de
la place beauvau à paris pour la
première fois donc le très privé système
de transmission diadème
sera accessible au grand public tous les
français vont avoir en même temps que
les autorités de la république et de
l'état
les résultats des élections dell qui
seront connus ici au ministère de
l'intérieur on a une idée ici au
ministère et c'est un des soucis du
ministre de rapprocher l'administration
des citoyens et donc c'est un pas de
plus dans cette démarche à caractère
général d'information des citoyens
je dirais en temps réel grâce aux moyens
modernes de télécommunication et
informatique à partir de 20h dimanche en
direct sur l'écran de votre minitel tous
les résultats au moment même où l'elysée
matignon et le ministère de l'intérieur
d re soir pour tout savoir donc minitel
36 15 codes cilic et au microscope ce
soir une ville comme chaque vendredi
soir depuis deux mois
et bien sûr nous terminons par la ville
qui sera sous les projecteurs durant
toute cette semaine c'est marseille
une bataille très serrée et difficile à
marseille
trois vedettes vigouroux peser good
chacun se présente dans un secteur
différents de marseille mais l'un de ces
trois-là sera le futur maire en arbitre
le front national roland sicard bernard
ap
jean claude gaudin fait campagne quand
vous re va tant il est vrai que le
patron la droite marseillaise joue gros
battu de justesse
il y a 6 ans il joue cette fois son va
tout avec la technique d'un vieux
routier de la politique
marcy n'a pas de vie le même si les
socialistes disent de thomas enlever les
pêcheurs c'est pas vrai la bonne humeur
est peut-être inspiré à jean claude
gaudin le style de sa fin de campagne
plus d'attaquants un tous ses
adversaires
un seul souci l'avenir de marseille moi
je n'ai pas d'ennemis je n'ai qu'un
ennemi c'est le déclin de marseille et
pour le second tour vous allez vous
entendre avec le front national et pour
l'instant les scellés marseillaise les
marseillais choisir je souhaite qu'ils
choisissent sûrement plonger sur mes
idées et sur mes propositions pour
marseille et après quoi
car les marseillais auront parlé on
verra ce qui aura lieu de faire et c'est
là que les choses se gâtent
jean marie le pen n'a pas fait le
déplacement mais gabriel domenech a
repris le flambeau du front national
dans une ville où insécurité et
immigration font toujours recette jours
mais ma mère est venue une fois
le front national lui joue sa carte sans
complexe et annonce la couleur pour le
second tour nous souhaiterions qu'avec
jean claude gaudin nous puissions
constituer une majorité parce que c'est
urgent avançait je crois que changer les
choses à lui maintenant de prendre la
responsabilité de la chose qu'il s'y
refuse tant pis pour lui division à
droite ont dû faire la ferme de michel
peser le candidat investi par le parti
socialiste et le parti communiste
seulement il y à robert vigouroux le
maire sortant affirme ne pas faire de
politique il est devenu la bête noire de
michel pesé lorsque je vois tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil regarde il faut pas faire de
politique
tout ça ça compte pas je rêve je rêve
est ce que vous estimez que vigouroux a
trahi le parti socialiste à marseille
bien sûr robert vigouroux qui laisse
dire et même campagne de père de famille
qui fait mouche à marseille et qu'on dit
ici ni té randy et pour prouver qu'être
bien devant d'immenses des marseillais
de la mère qui s'occupe de leur dise
qu'ils se consacrent à leur deal cse
c'est ce qui les intéresse parce que ils
connaissent l'enjeu pour le futur
les politiciens les intéressent moins
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir le
soutien de l'elysée ou pas eh bien on le
dit alors je le laisse dire j'en suis
heureux vigouroux peser domenech
gaudin quatre candidats c'est beaucoup
mais comme on dit à marseille le 19 mars
un seul d'entre eux ne restera pas sur
le cac perd marseille l'un des grands
problèmes c'est l'opposition entre le
sud et le nord d'un côté le port et ses
alentours les quartiers les plus riches
au nord les cités qui abrite les plus
pauvres mais aussi la délinquance et le
racisme
patrice volée et jean-françois giorgetti
ont enquêté dans ces quartiers nord ils
ont voulu savoir comment on y vivait
reportage
vivre au nord là haut dans les quartiers
loin de l'aisance du centre la campagne
fenouil habitat bidonvilles jamais
résorber depuis trente ans quarante
familles environ gitans harkis ou de
pieds-noirs leurs enfants sont nés ici
les hommes n'ont pas de travail fixe
impossible de payer un voeu loyer
vous allez voir où leur vie mais la vie
en ville les allocations qu'on vivre
cette famille une maison de fortune pour
neuf enfants l'électricité sur un
compteur collectif ça coûte moins cher
et surtout pas d'eau au robinet et pour
le petit tous les collèges et il pèse
pas que sa personne oui on l'a dit alors
vis par vis pas envie d'en faire alors
elle rêve cette mère de famille d'un
véritable appartement à plan d'aou par
exemple une cité qui endosse toute la
mauvaise réputation des quartiers nord
une cité rejeté sur la colline par des
murs d'exclusion 50 % des logements
inoccupés car insalubre ici depuis deux
ans la réhabilitation est en marche il
faut restructurer la cité offrir des
appartements rénovés
c'est pas mal c'est habitable la fin c
était trop vite frites allen et par
rapport à votre ancien logement c'est
mieux avoue islami art et musique et à
la 20e humilité cas n a pas s'échauffer
soit déviée pas mal si bien les dizaines
de familles ont ainsi trouvé un nouveau
cadre de vie
l'occasion pour le centre social
d'équilibrer les relations dans la cité
on a essayé
d'accompagner sa socialement savoir des
pas
mettre des gens et puis
on
la gtz et donc ça c'était un travail
disons très beau très proche de la
population
la vita dans les quartiers nord un enjeu
important dans la campagne municipale
mais ici on a pu passer plus de vingt
ans de promesses électorales très
souvent sans beaucoup de résultats enfin
au delà du cas particulier marseille au
delà de tous les problèmes locaux que ce
soit lyon à paris ou dans les petites
villes
il y a un enjeu pour ces élections un
enjeu national jean rieux scène soul et
r&b traditionnellement en france
l'élection municipale élections de
proximité par excellence a toujours fait
recette
la première inconnue du scrutin de
dimanche est donc le taux de
participation les électeurs se
sentiront-ils aussi peu motivés par ces
municipales que par les dernières
législatives
les dernières cantonales ou encore le
référendum sur la nouvelle calédonie à
gauche comme à droite certains le
redoutent
comme s'il craignait une confirmation
par les français d'un rejet global de
leur classe politique
pourtant à quelques exceptions près
force est de constater que la campagne
des municipales a été cette année
beaucoup moins politisés quand 83 il ne
reste pas moins que ce type d'élections
demeure un test de l'état de la nation
un test de l'état des partis politiques
un test de l'état de la nation parce que
neuf mois après le retour des causses
socialiste aux affaires
les électeurs ne manqueront pas de
s'exprimer également sur l'ouverture
fermé sur les conflits sociaux en cours
ou sur l'éducation nationale le dernier
dossier mise en avant par le
gouvernement rocard un test de l'état
des formations politiques parce que ps
et pc malgré un accord particulièrement
laborieux n'ont pas pu éviter 40% de
primaire dans les villes de plus de 20
mille habitants qu'ils ont désormais
chacun leurs dissidents et leurs excuses
parce qu'à droite
la situation n'est guère plus brillante
95% de liste commune c'est vrai mais
combien d'une façade et de primaire
sauvage tout cela peut ajouter au
malaise ambiant sauf sauf si les
électeurs se souviennent attend que des
municipales c'est avant tout fait pour
élire une équipe et un m
merci jean louis les obsèques de patrice
pelât elle avait lieu aujourd'hui à la
ferté saint aubin en sologne le
président mitterrand a assisté en fin de
matinée à ses obsèques
patrice pelât était son ami il avait dû
espaces et ses relations avec lui depuis
l'inculpation de monsieur plat dans la
sphère pechiney
la presse n'a pas été admise à l'office
à la demande de la famille
auparavant le président français avait
achevé sa visite en algérie il avait eu
près de dix heures d'entretien avec le
président bendjedid tous les
observateurs ont constaté une embellie
dans les relations entre les deux pays
c'est important au moment où l'algérie
ce coup il ya quatre mois par des
émeutes sans précédent où l'algérie
aborde un tournant capital et
démocratique de son histoire
enfin cet après midi le président
français s'est envolé pour las et un
sommet qui va rassembler 23 pays au
programme la création d'un nouvel
organisme de protection de
l'environnement et notamment de
l'atmosphère
l'attak de la couche d'ozone la
déforestation de l'amazonie où les
menaces sur l'antarctique montre qu'il
faut peu de choses pour que l'équilibré
écologique de notre terre bascule
c'est ce dont on parlera à la haie et
nous en nous vous en rendrons compte
tout au long du week end
george bush à bien des ennuis syli à la
faillite dit stern airlines
il y a caméras une caméra de je ne sais
plus la faillite dit stern airlines mais
il ya aussi et surtout le refus du sénat
d'accepter john towers communiste de la
défense une claque pour le nouveau
président américain
jacquat bouchard à washington le vote du
sénat donc mis fin à un véritable
cauchemar pour le candidat de george
bush dont les faits et gestes étaient
examinés au microscope
depuis trois mois humilié par le sénat
après seulement 50 jours de présence à
la maison blanche george bush fait lui
aussi figure de victime
oui c'est une grande défaite pour
monsieur bush surtout en début d'année
ministration mais il n'y a pas atteint
mortellement et je crois qu'il va faire
un grand effort et le progrès aussi pour
travailler ensemble dans les jours qui
viennent et cette impression de vide à
la tête des états unis qu'ils en
pensaient oui je crois que tous les
américains ont peu une impression que
l'administration n'a pas défini ses
priorités et que sur le plan domestique
aussi bien que sur le plan international
on attend encore les grandes lignes soit
bien établie après son élection george
bush avait reçu un accueil favorable de
la part du congrès où l'opposition
démocrate majoritaire avait mené la vie
dure à ronald reagan
or les élus s'inquiètent du flottement
de la nouvelle équipe
le secrétaire d'état james baker a bien
rencontré monsieur chez bernatchez par
exemple mais les relations avec moscou
sont en sommeil ce qui est vrai pour la
politique étrangère et la défense et
également pour le budget on ne sait
toujours pas comment la nouvelle
administration va s'y prendre pour
réduire l'énorme déficit et ses idées
reste également floue dans des domaines
aussi critique que la lutte contre la
drogue ou l'éducation
en un mot george bush s'avance dans le
brouillard à pas comptés et son message
passe mal
un étrange attentats aux etats unis une
bombe qui a détruit la voiture dans
laquelle se trouvait la femme du
commandant du navire vincennes nous
venons de l'apprendre
souvenez-vous le vincennes dont le port
d'attaché six ans diego
là où a eu lieu l'attentât le vincennes
c'est ce bateau qui avait abattu par
erreur un airbus iranien en juillet 88
madame rodgers la femme du commandant a
échappé miraculeusement à cet attentat
d'autres informations internationales
tout de suite éric perrin
nouvelle arrestation aujourd'hui à
lhassa capitale du tibet où règne
toujours la loi martiale
depuis l'expulsion jeudi des touristes
étrangers la répression c'est en contre
les tibétains qui réclamait violemment
ce début de semaine
l'indépendance de leur pays annexé en 59
par la chine tout en critiquant
sévèrement l'entourage du dalaï lama
l'écart n'a pas fermé la porte au très
populaire chef spirituel
actuellement exilé en inde
le pouvoir et le syndicat solidarité se
met d'accord sur le principe d'élections
totalement libre ce compromis qui
signifie la fin de l'omnipotence du pc
polonais au sein du parlement prévoit
également la constitution d'une deuxième
chambre parlementaire le sénat ce
scrutin qui pourraient se dérouler en
juin serait une première dans l'histoire
du bloc communiste de l'après guerre
la roumanie lâché par ses alliés du
pacte de varsovie en s'abstenant de
voter l'urss l'ukraine la rda et la
bulgarie ont permis à l'onu de condamner
le régime de nicolae ceauscescu pour je
cite ces graves violations des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
depuis plus de huit ans les roumains
vivent dans la pénurie forcé de nombreux
villages ont été détruits et les
minorités déplacés par la force la
sphère rush 10 et ses conséquences
dernier volet de notre enquête qui nous
a mené toute la semaine dans les
communautés musulmanes d'algérie de
grande-bretagne et d'allemagne
ce soir bien sûr la france en france la
communauté musulmane est éclatée les
dignitaires religieux et c'est
maintenant de se regrouper
ils veulent adopter une position modérée
et communes dans la sphère rue jeudi
pascal des changes actuel
reportage pour la première fois les
imams des principales associations
musulmanes
réunis à la mosquée de paris à la faveur
de l'affairé rushdie
ils vont essayer de surmonter leurs
divisions et d'adopter une ligne de
conduite commune
condamné à la fois l'appel au meurtre de
khomeiny est le livre de salman rushdie
positions modérées de chefs religieux
soucieux de rester dans les limites de
la légalité française personne n'est ni
même comédie n'est qu'avec un autre n'a
le droit de lancer cet appel au meurtre
le livre lui est condamnable et doit
être dans la mesure du possible condamné
interdit de publication et de diffusion
en france il touche blesse lots france
les musulmans dans ce qu'ils ont de plus
cher au profond de plus profond de leur
coeur oui c'est vrai que nous ne pouvons
pas faire grand chose mais nous allons
essayer par des voies légales et pour le
bien de tous d'éviter la parution du
livre de rugby un comité de coordination
va donc étudier les possibilités d'une
action en justice
la communauté musulmane à temps mais
elle sent bien que la faire et ses excès
lui auront fait beaucoup de mal
abdellatif laâbi est écrivain marocain
laïque mais attaché à sa culture
arabo-musulmane partisans de la
publication du livre
il regrette toutefois que tout ce qui
touche à l'islam entraînent des
réactions passionnées
on ne peut pas reprocher au christ
l'acquisition est intervenue plus tard
dans la chrétienneté on ne peut pas non
plus rentrer coupable prophète de
l'islam des divagations d'un khomeiny je
crois qu'il faut faire très attention à
cela si on veut avoir de l'islam donc
qui est la foi de d'un milliard de
personnes à travers la planète
une idée correcte et juste peur des
dérapages peur de l'amalgamé les jeunes
issus de l'immigration se sentent les
premiers touchés ceux qui croient au
ciel comme ceux qui n'y croient pas dans
cette cité de stains ils craignent que
la sphère ruines des années d'efforts
pour l'intégration logement du monde
c'est quelque chose de tolérance est
quelque chose de ouvert et je pense que
des intégristes en faisant les
manifestations réclamant mort ne font
que ternir l'image du du musulman en
france
est-ce que vous en avez parlé avec vos
parents cette affaire disons oui où j'en
ai parlé donc comme moi ils condamnent
le livre mais ils vont pas jusqu'à
réclamer la tête de l'auteur quoi est ce
que vous vous êtes partisan de la
publication de ce livre en france jeudi
la publication il peut être publié ça à
chacun de prendre ses responsabilités en
le lisant
le disant pas finalement les jeunes ce
qu'ils en pensent en fin de compte ils
ont d'autres choses à penser sont des
problèmes problèmes du quotidien as à
dire recherche d'un emploi une formation
d'un logement
il ya beaucoup de problèmes qu'on devra
aborder plutôt que se pencher sur un
problème qui n'en est pas un pour ces
jeunes la féroce jeudi est avant tout
politique est venu d'ailleurs ils ne
veulent surtout pas en souffrir
en corse il n'y aura peut-être pas de
soirée électorale fr3 corse est en grève
comme toute la fonction publique de
l'île de beauté la grève est très suivie
75% des salariés
l'île est paralysée même si le calme est
revenu
françoise joly et à ajaccio c'est ici
dans ce centre de tri d'ajaccio qu'il y
a quinze jours les premiers salariés de
la fonction publique se sont mis en
grève parce qu'ici on parle encore avec
amertume d'une autre grève celles de
l'automne dernier trois semaines de
conflit qui s'était soldée par un échec
aujourd'hui les revendications sont
toujours les mêmes plus d'argent et
c'est le coût de la vie sur l'île s'ils
misent en invente n'importe qui qui
vient encore ce même le touriste qui
arrive chez nous il se rend compte que
la vie elle est chère des fois il nous
demande à nous même s'il ya pas un prix
spécial corse il ya pas un prix spécial
continentaux pin's outre on est est ce
que c'est pas fait exprès c'est rigolo
et pourtant nous à chaque début d'été
par exemple on perd on paye cette cette
insularité là il ya les commerçants que
ça y'a des gens qui profitent de faire
monter les prix
depuis plusieurs jours les salariés de
la sécurité sociale ceux de l'équipement
ou encore les pompiers ont rejoint les
grévistes des ptt paralysant ainsi une
bonne partie des services publics
un exemple à moins de 48 heures des
élections municipales le courrier n'est
distribué au compte gouttes dans ce
village de 300 habitants beaucoup gnagno
là on attend encore les procurations de
vote
donc on a un compte entre 81 80 des
procurations un choc le scrutin est ici
pour le moment il y en a un peu plus de
donc la grève gêne considérablement de
déroulement du scrutin
c'est vrai le gouvernement attend le
rapport de son envoyé spécial sur la
situation de la fonction publique en
corse
les grévistes eux demandent un
négociateur et menace de faire monter la
pression
un policier inculpé après la mort
un surveillant de la brink's peut-être
une bavure la victime est un agent de
surveillance de la brink's qui était
soupçonné dans une affaire de vol de
bijoux à ivry-sur-seine trop crespo
derrière ces murs les locaux de la brb
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi un
gardien de la paix accompagne toilettes
bernard le quellec 25 ans accusé de
complicité dans un vol
premier scénario présenté par la police
ce dernier sujet sur lui lui arrache son
arme de service
la retourne contre lui et se tue mais
dès le lendemain la police des polices
déclenché une enquête
résultat le policier est aujourd'hui
inculpé pour homicide involontaire
au départ pourtant un banal vol de
bijoux dans cet entrepôt de la région
parisienne spécialisée dans la
joaillerie en gros le guellec gardien la
brink's serait complice d'un malfaiteur
auteur d'un casque d'un million de
francs ce dernier arrêté depuis
ni ce vol dans cette affaire on ignore
encore à cette heure les circonstances
de la mort du vigile
le dossier est maintenant entre les
mains du juge christine fort qu'elle
la télévision et les enfants ou plus
précisément cette fois la télévision et
l'enseignement un rapport vient d'être
présenté au ministre de l'éducation par
jacques pomonti
prof à la sorbonne et ancien président
de l'ina il était particulièrement
qualifiés donc pour juger de l'outil
télévision pour enseigner aux enfants
pour l'instant c'est plutôt la méfiance
mutuelle la télévision progresse dans
l'enseignement mais très très doucement
serge ministre s est rendu dans un lycée
le lycée louise-michel de champigny
dominique bernot et prof de sciences nat
elle a enregistré ce programme à la télé
pour améliorer son cours
symbole d'une évolution après la maison
la télévision entre à l'école désormais
pour les professeurs comme pour les
élèves ce n'est pas un plus mais une
nécessité
je passe à des blocs
la façon de voir les choses
pour donner les images
une fois est un récepteur la discussion
s'engage
il ya un autre animal qui intervient
elsa élèves et professeurs communiquent
ils communiquent mieux
la télé est devenue l'auxiliaire
indispensable de l'enseignant plus avec
la télévision on retrouve quelque chose
qui le connaissent bien ils font
concentré sur cet écran et il est
certain que sur les enfants l'image de
la télévision un pouvoir que les autres
d'image non
depuis quatre ans le proviseur de ce
lycée de banlieue a choisi la télévision
pour lui s'il faut un budget des moyens
caméra récepteur il faut aussi former
les enseignants c'est toute une
pédagogie suffit pas de pas si on se
contentait de passer à l'élève il
émission comme ça on en voit là vous
avez vu chat etc
non parce qu'il faut que le professeur
travaille dessus il faut qu'ils sachent
que choisir il faut qu'il fasse
travailler les élèves un petit peu comme
vous l'avez eue de madame bardot en fait
c'est un support mais ça demande
d'adapter la taille si ça c'est pas du
tout évident ici ce n'est qu'une
expérience originale certes mais
expérience qui marchent ouvrir un
récepteur comme on ouvre un manuel
scolaire c'est peut-être déjà demain
l'auteur du rapport jacques pomonti est
en direct avec nous alors bonsoir
monsieur pomonti
dites moi au fond pourquoi utiliser la
télé pour enseigner aux enfants
pourraient s'en passer il ajouté il
s'agit pas de n'utiliser que la
télévision ou bien entendu
l'apprentissage d'éducation c'est
d'abord les parents et les enfants et
les enseignants
ceci étant la télévision fait partie de
notre univers commun et en particulier
fait partie de l'univers des enfants et
ce serait je dirais un crime contre le
modernisme contre cette vie moderne que
de ne pas utiliser la télévision comme
l'un des outils effectivement de l'aide
à l'apprentissage scolaire tissage à
l'information
elle est incontournable maintenant comme
on dit je sais pas si j'utilise ray
cette expression effectivement mais elle
est incontournable puisqu'elle fait
encore une fois parti d'univers
quotidienne tous nos enfants
mais alors à quelles conditions peut-on
utiliser dans l'enseignement est-ce
qu'il faut pas d'abord avec l plaire aux
enfants les séduire
oui
il faut que enseignants et
professionnels de la communication
professionnelle télévision comme
vous-même travailler ensemble c'est ce
qui se fait le plus difficilement le
plus mal en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est ce que j'ai constaté dans mon
enquête
il faut qu'ils travaillent ensemble
parce que sinon c'est l'échec
il faut que un programme qui auraient
été fabriqués sans prendre en compte la
logique de l'enseignant et sa manière de
raisonner ne pourrait pas être maîtrisé
par lui il aurait des difficultés
effectivement à être le médiateur entre
la matière enseignée et l'élève et de la
même manière que je dirai et je le sais
que un programme audiovisuel a besoin du
concours des professionnels de la
télévision parce que c'est une
discipline c'est une technique c'est un
savoir faire
dernier point vous avez enquêté auprès
des enseignants aussi là ils sont pas
très chauds pour utiliser la télévision
il cotait les choses ont beaucoup évolué
et j'avais déjà a conduit des enquêtes
de cette nature il y a quelques années
je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui la
situation a beaucoup évolué au contraire
au cours de cette enquête de trois mois
et demi j'ai vu plus de j'ai eu plus de
300 réunions de travail et je peux vous
dire que j'ai senti au contraire un état
d'esprit très curieux très ouvert
parfois même inquiet parce que comme le
disait tout à l'heure ce professeur de
lycée il y a l'inquiétude de ne pas être
tout à fait prêt à ce nouveau défi qui
leur est qu'il aurait imposée mais au
contraire une évolution très certaines
très ouvert c'est très encourageant à
l'emploi merci jacques pomonti et puis
pour terminer ce journal et bien nous
allons passer un petit peu de musique
voilà un sujet tout à fait éducatif avec
une saison entière consacrée à un seul
compositeur c'est le sacre de gustav
mahler au théâtre du châtelet à paris
c'est un pari difficile mais pas très
risqué puisque les amateurs de mahler et
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux se
précipitent c'est quasiment plein
jusqu'au 10 mai
mahler a de plus en plus de succès
peut-être que vous ne le connaissez pas
encore mais écoutez ces premières
mesures et vous vous souviendrez sans
doute du film de visconti mort à venise
george v go yves dreux
où
le dernier des romantiques gustav mahler
célébré comme chef d'orchestre autant ou
rodin sculpté son buste était sifflée au
châtelet en tant que compositeur 80 ans
plus tard on fait la queue pour les 22
concerts qui lui sont consacrés par la
volonté du nouveau directeur stéphane
lissner qui a invité les meilleurs
orchestres les meilleurs chefs en
apparence une folie sur le plan
financier c'est très cher mais en même
temps
comparativement quand on voit ce que
coûte une intégrale comme la tegra le
malheur de la vie de la subvention que
nous avons ça devient une chose tout à
fait raisonnable et alors ça l'est
encore plus aujourd'hui quand on peut
dire que la plupart des concerts vont
être complet donc là pour nous c'est une
grande satisfaction évidemment sur le
plan également économique puis
évidemment sur le plan artistique de
penser qu' on va réunir 60 à 70 milles
personnes pendant trois mois autour d'un
compositeur qui quand même les quelques
années n'était pas aussi évident à
l'époque en caricature et sa musique et
même son personnage en 1900 les
préoccupations de la jeunesse était plus
légère que celle d'aujourd'hui ceux qui
touchent le public en cette fin de
siècle ce sont à la fois les angoisses
existentielles qu'il traduit et les
souffrances personnelles amoureuse
on sait que sa femme alma ne fut pas la
plus douce et la plus soumise dès et
pour
en liaison avec les concerts du chapelet
les passionnés peuvent visiter à paris
une exposition très riche en photos
manuscrits et objets car la bibliothèque
musicale mahler de la rue de ben et cela
est à ce sujet la plus importante du
monde
on peut s'y promener rêver entendre
également l'ensemble de leurs
voilà vont terminer complètement ce
journal cette information dernière
minute le banquier libanais roger tamraz
ce qui était pour suivre poursuivi par
la police est porté disparu depuis près
de deux semaines et bien été retrouvée
puisqu'il est apparu vendredi dans un
hôtel de beyrouth-ouest on avait dit
cette semaine que ce banquier dont le
nom a été cité dans la sphère pechiney
vous en souvenez que ce banquier avait
été enlevé donc il est réapparu tout à
l'heure tout de suite les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour le tiercé c'est
demain samedi sur l'hippodrome de
maisons laffitte le 1 le 11 le 9 le 10
le 15 le 13 le 6 et le 4 fin de ce
journal la météo tout de suite c'est
laurent cabrol dernière édition philippe
gassot vers 23 heures aussitôt après
apostrophes et puis demain et comme tous
les week-ends daniel bilalian avec betty
dureau et philippe gassot vous
informerons lundi 20h vous retrouverez
christine ockrent
bonne soirée